sie hätte noch leben können und sie
würde noch leben wenn eine Politik
gehandelt hätte wie viele von ihnen
wissen oder der ein oder andere nicht
ich bin eine bekanntesten Kinderschützer
in Deutschland und aufgrund meiner
Arbeit mit Millionen von Menschen die
die begleiten und verfolgen bekomme ich
viele Hilfe rufen und ich habe direkt
nach diesem Mord an Ecke ein Video
gemacht und habe da sehr klare deutliche
Worte gefunden und dann haben wir auch
Menschen aus dieser Stadt geschrieben
aus diesem kleinen Ort in der Kirche
oder in der Kirchberg und haben mir
Dinge gesagt Dinge die bekannt waren und
jetzt noch öffentlich werden und die
öffentlich machen werden auch in BILD am
SONNTAG und noch anderen Medien Dinge
die man komischerweise in anderen Medien
nicht erfährt so wurde schon im Sommer
diesen Jahres immer wieder die Stadt der
Bürgermeister auf hingewiesen dass da
Übergriffe waren Kinder auch verfolgt
wurden belästigt wurden von diesen
Menschen die dort auch in diesem
Wohnheim waren